People LOVE conspiracy theories, but even
when they're presented with the truth, they're
still... dumb about it.
[[MUSIC PLAYING]]
Hey everyone, Trace here reporting for DNews.
I'm going to start here and say, right now.
Science doesn't know what CAUSES autism; there's
a lot of misinformation out there, but it's
really that...
MISinformation.
We're talking about this because half of Americans.
HALF.
Believe in at least one medical conspiracy
theory, according to a recent survey published
in JAMA Internal Medicine.
In general, Americans are a pretty easy bunch
to fool, apparently.
We're susceptible to a lot of conspiracy nonsense.
We didn't land on the moon, bigfoot exists,
Elvis is alive, Roswell saw aliens, cell phones
cause cancer, and the FDA and Big Pharma are
colluding to keep people sick.
Regardless, they've all been debunked at one
point or another.
We believe these crappy theories thanks to
the power of evolution.
Thousands of years ago when we were living
in the cradle of humanity, we needed to assume
there was a malevolent predator rustling in
the bushes so we'd be ready to flee for our
lives.
Still today, when we're afraid and ill-informed,
it's human instinct to assume someone is in
the bushes, and their intent is bad.
In the end, even education fails to help.
People prefer the complex narrative they've
invented over the reality.
Really though, if you teach your kid we didn't
land on the moon, she'll eventually learn
the truth.
It's not going to hurt anyone, just make some
people angry.
Buzz Aldrin decked a guy who accused him of
lying.
But, if you refuse to vaccinate people, out
of a misguided attempt to prevent them acquiring
autism -- that's a lifelong problem for YOUR
child AND others.
Also, if it hasn't showed up by the time you're
older, you're not going to CATCH autism.
So, get your adult vaccines.
A study in the journal of Pediatrics looked
at the total number of vaccines children are
given in the first year of life and found
the CDC's schedule of vaccinations to be completely
unrelated to autism.
Since this study was conducted, vaccines have
improved.
They're less invasive, and more targeted.
The U.K. Department of Health, the CDC, and
the Institute of Medicine have all studied
this too, thanks to Mrs. Jenny McCarthy's
uneducated belief in medical science's conspiracy.
No one has found a statistically significant
link in a repeatable, peer-reviewed paper.
Saying what CAUSES autism is problematic.
The journal Cell published evidence a brain
circuit gene called SynGAP1 might be part
of the cause, another study found flu in the
mother night influence the genes too, but
scientists are still working on it.
Though the number of children with autism
is increasing today, the first patient called
"Case 1" was discovered in 1943 -- and we've
been inoculating humans against disease since
the 1790s!
The science and advocacy organization, Autism
Speaks, has EVERY REASON to find the cause
of this neurodevelopmental disorder, so they
can repair it.
They say it's GENES which set the stage, and
possibly ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS to control
when it manifests and how.
They know the diet of a pregnant mother can
lower the risk, there's a connection to folic
acid... but their scientifically-focused medical
advice is extremely clear on this point: There
is no evidence that vaccines cause autism,
none.
The consequences of NOT vaccinating populations
of young people WILL BE the resurgence of
diseases beaten back by generations of Americans.
Hopefully, we realize that thing rustling
the bushes isn't a vaccine, but the only thing
we should fear; fear itself.
What's your belief?
Why do you think vaccines are demonized?
Tell us below.
Come for the facts stay for the debate.
Thanks for watching DNews, please subscribe
and go to the App Store to try the new TestTube
app!
It's shiny!